before i continue i want to introduce
you to what might be an unfamiliar
concept although if you've taken
chemistry you you might know a little
bit about it it's called a mole
and this isn't the thing that grows on
on your face with a hair in it or the
animal that digs in your backyard
although those are also called
moles but we're talking about the s i
unit called a mole and a mole is just a
number it's like saying
a mole of something means a certain
number of something just like a dozen or
a
well i don't know what other things are
there are numbers but it's like saying
you know a dozen eggs is 12 eggs right
a dozen
equals 12.
well just like that a mole a mole of
eggs
would be
six i always forget the exact number
it's
6.023 i think
something of that of that nature six
point you could look it up i
i think it's 6.023 times 10 to the 20.
let me look it up actually the right the
exact number just because i think i'm
that that 23 i'm
i miss uh misremembering
let's see the si the
the mole i'm on wikipedia now and i'm i
just looked up uh
the mole
okay there you go on wikipedia see it's
very easy oh yeah i was close it's 6.022
6.022 times 10 to 23 of something so
it's a very it's a very large number of
something so normally we don't deal in
moles of eggs i don't think there have
been a mole of eggs ever produced in the
history of universe 10 to the 23 is a
very very very large number so where is
it useful well a mole is useful for
counting atoms
and and so what what is a mole of atoms
well it's that it's that or molecules
what's that many molecules it's six
followed by roughly 23 zeros of
molecules very very big number but
what's interesting about a mole is that
when i have a mole of something
it's
mass so
let's say it's it's mass in grams so
let's say a mole
mole of carbon
its mass in grams is going to be equal
to
so mass and it's a mole of carbon if i
have a mole so if i have this many
carbon molecules its mass in grams
it'll have x grams
it'll it'll have a mass of x grams where
x
is the atomic mass number
atomic
mass
of
of a atom of carbon although if i was
taking about a mole of a molecule i
would figure out the atomic mass of the
entire molecule so what's an atomic mass
number let me see if i can
if i can do a web search on a on a
periodic table see i'm showing you what
i do here
i don't know it's not fancy
so let me let me go to google
google.com and let's look up periodic
table let's see if we can find a good
one
periodic table
this one looks good
let's see
what i can do
sometimes it up
oh
no looks like everything is freezing up
too oh there you go
so periodic table of elements good
let's see what we can do
so if we go to carbon which is right
here
we see that it's it's atomic number six
and that's the number of protons it has
but let's see if i can zoom in on carbon
what happens
the periodic table oh there you go
that's pretty neat
so the atomic mass number it's the mass
of the entire atom and just so you know
i mean we're kind of delving into a
little bit of chemistry here but most of
the mass of an atom is the protons and
the neutrons and the neutrons and the
protons
weigh roughly the same thing and then
the electrons are much much much smaller
so if you if you pretty much factor in
the mass of the protons and the neutrons
you pretty much have the mass of the
particle and then just another a little
more chemistry here is that
although on average most of the most of
the atoms have roughly the same number
of protons and neutrons some don't some
you know you could have a carbon atom
that has
you know seven neutrons you could have
another one that has five another one
with six so and those are actually all
called isotopes and i won't go into all
of that but they're just the same atom
with different numbers of neutrons but
in general the atomic mass number just
if you had a kind of a broad rule of
thumb is is equal to
um sorry the atomic mass is equal to the
mass of the protons and the neutrons and
they tend to be equal so if the atomic
number is 6 the mass 10 the atomic mass
tends to be 12. so why is this useful
so we can say if we have i don't know
what is this gallium
if i have a mole of gallium
right let me actually let me you can
let's say
niobium let's say i have a mole of
niobium if we look here on this uh on
the periodic table it has an atomic mass
number of 41 and then its average atomic
mass if we were to average all of the
isotopes or kind of how how you know
based on the weighting of how they exist
in nature it's 92.9 so roughly 93 so
it's actually a little bit more than
double its atomic number but let's say
it's a 92 point let's let's say 93. so
if we had a mole of niobium if we had 6
6.022
times 10 to the 23 of niobium
we it would weigh
it would not weigh it would have a mass
of 92 grams so that's pretty easy you
look at any element molybdenum the mat
you know we see here oh whoops
let's say chromium we see its atomic
mass number is roughly f atomic mass is
roughly 52 we see that there
so if i have a mole of it if i have 6
times 10
roughly 6 times 10 to the 23 of it
that much will have a mass of 52 grams
so that's how we think about a mole so
if i tell you i have a mole of something
i'm also telling you how many of that a
molecule i have on the and i'm also
telling you how what the mass of that
mole of that mole that quantity will be
um if assuming that you have a periodic
table in front of you so with that said
with that out of the way let's do some
let's make some more progress with our
thermodynamics
invert colors
so we said in the last several videos
let me see when i'm running out of time
i have plenty of time that pressure
times volume
pressure times volume is somehow
proportional it's somehow proportional
you know let's call that k and this is
an arbitrary number it's not some
special constant to the total kinetic
energy kinetic energy total of a system
total
and we also said that that is equal that
that is
um
roughly
proportional
you know that's some constant that's
another constant
times the number
of ob the number of of
molecules we have times the temperature
because temperature we viewed as kinetic
energy per molecule right
so in general we could also say that
you know this is proportional to this
which is proportional to this that
pressure times volume
is equal to
is proportional and we'll use
r because you'll see where that's that's
coming from in a second
it's it's proportional it's equal to
some constant times the number of
molecules
n
and when i write a small n here see here
i was just saying the absolute numbers
if i had five molecules i put a five
here but now this n i'm counting in
moles
right so if i say i have if this n is
one that means i have six times 6.02 two
times 10 to the 23
molecule so let me see one mole
equals 6.022
times 10 to the 23. right
so i'm just saying so this is just
another way to write the number of
molecules and then that's times
temperature
and then if we rearrange it
pv
equals nrt
we have a relationship that if i know
the pressure and the volume and the
number of molecules i can figure out the
temperature or if i know the number of
molecules the temperature and the
pressure i can figure out the volume
assuming assuming i know what r is
and i'm about to tell you what that is r
is called the universal gas constant and
it is
r is 8.31
joules
per
joules per mole kelvin
and that kind of tells you what you need
in this in this
in in this formula this should end up
being joules
right so if you have this if you have
pressure in pascals and you have volume
in meters cubed you'll end up with
joules there this should be in moles
moles
this is 8.31 joules per mole kelvin and
then this as we always said should be in
kelvin
and honestly if you if you just memorize
two things in all the thermodynamics
you'll probably be able to do 95 of
problems but you actually should have
the intuition of how they work but just
remember that p over pv over t is equal
to a constant or that
if you change them they relate to each
other that you know they all equal a
constant so if p1 times v1 divided by t1
is equal to p2 times v2 divided by t2
and then
you and then you also should just need
to memorize pv is equal to nrt
where r is equal to 8.31 joules per mole
kelvin
and i know you might not have a lot of
intuition of this formula yet because i
haven't used it but i'm going to do that
in the next video but these are these
are literally the two most important
things you should know in thermodynamics
and hopefully you have a little
intuition at this point of what they
mean see you soon